sería factible que tropas de la ONU sean
enviadas hasta Haití
Buenas noches Ángela sea factible porque
ya ya está hecho el pedido de manera
oficial por el gobierno de factor de
arieragi pero este periodo es un período
hecho por este gobierno no es realmente
el peligro del pueblo haitiano hay que
tener en cuenta de que ellos ya hace
unos días empiezan a decir a no escuchar
los reclamos del pueblo por eso mandaron
este periodo el pueblo está diciendo que
no quieren una universidad de fuerza
pero ya se está definido que va a ir uno
una fuerza de la ONU en este momento o
de fuerzas internacionales de otro país
en el territorio haitiano para decir
garantizar seguridad una seguridad una
violación de los violaciones de derechos
en Haití que no datan de hoy que vienen
ya de muchos años bueno Y mientras tanto
mientras se suscita digamos esta
polémica por la llega eventual de tropas
internacionales ante el secuestro de
combustible por las bandas armadas hay
negocios y hospitales que ya tuvieron
que suspender sus actividades y además
hay escasez de botellas de agua potable
que se puede hacer con este contexto
frente a los nuevos brotes de cólera
hay que ver que los bandas armadas ya
venían y tienen su relación con el
gobierno de infarto y ya les Ya ellos
sabían que iba a llegar a esta condición
y no es una cuestión de esta semana
porque es lo que se está viendo es ahora
no no es una cuestión de esta semana
pero viene ya de muchos muchos días y
muchos meses lo que se puede hacer es
dejar de alimentar el país en armas es
una de las cosas que estamos pidiendo y
que el gobierno empieza de facto que sea
que empiezan a negociar con
sus aliados que son estas ondas armadas
para que dejan que circule El
combustible en el país este falta de
combustible si a garantizado ha hecho
que no hay escuela que se deberían abrir
el 3 de octubre pasado que no abrieron
la cera de los hospitales como si bien
usted ha mencionado Pero esto venía
desde más de un año con este gobierno
hoy ya se dan cuenta que no pueden
seguir manejando el país así no pueden
seguir manteniendo el pueblo en este
sufrimiento y están pidiendo tropas
internacionales la policía en Haití
tiene fuerza para actuar hay que darle
autoridad hay que darle posibilidad a la
policía ya la para que intervenga en
esta condiciones